والليلة لدينا أيضًا تفاصيل جديدة حصرية
حول التعزيزات العسكرية لبوتين
وفقًا لسيث جونز الذي
سأتحدث معه في غضون لحظة ، وأريد
أن أتحدث معك ، حيث يوجد الآن ما يصل
إلى 190 ألف جندي في أوكرانيا وحولها.
أريكم هذه الصور الجديدة الحصرية التي
تتضمن 105
مجموعة تكتيكية كتيبة تتكون من
600 إلى 1000 جندي لكل منها 500
طائرة مقاتلة و 40 سفينة
قتالية وداخل إحدى تلك
المناطق الانفصالية في أوكرانيا
سيث قدمت لنا هذه الصور الحصرية
واسمحوا لي أن أخبركم
يظهر هذا واحد ناقلات جند
مدرعة وشاحنات روسية في منطقة تدريب
مرة أخرى داخل إحدى تلك
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها الانفصاليون في أوكرانيا في تلك
الصورة ترى مركبات القتال المدرعة
والمدفعية ذاتية الدفع
وهنا 27 دبابة روسية إلى جانب
المزيد من ناقلات الجند المدرعة
والشاحنات
و  في ما قد يكون أعظم
استعراض للقوة حتى الآن ،
سيحضر الرئيس الروسي غدًا تدريبات عسكرية
حيث الباليستية والكر  سيتم اختبار صواريخ uise ،
وهي بالطبع بعض
أقوى أسلحة بوتين وروسيا وأكثرها
فتكًا ، وكلها معروضة بشكل صارخ
غدًا